Republican Senator Jeff Flake believes
the GOP is no longer conservative in his
new book conscience of a conservative
the Arizona senator writes quote never
has a party so quickly or easily
abandoned its core principles as my
party did in the course of the 2016
campaign we alerts like a tranquilized
elephant from a broad consensus on
economic philosophy and free trade to an
incoherent and often untrue mash a
back-of-the-envelope popular slogans
senator platon is with us now welcome
thanks Raph me on every read from the
New York Times this morning a seemingly
in the sequence of disappointments and
blunders have rattled mr. Trump volatile
governing coalition like mr. Trump's
attacks on turn gentle session the bull
vulgar TRAI tirade buys communications
cheap and the collapse of a conservative
backed health care legislation so what
happened why is this happening well you
know being a conservative it doesn't
just mean that you adhere to
conservative policy limited government
economic freedom individual
responsibility it means you're
conservative in comportment as well your
demeanor that you you you know in a
foreign policy a conservative is nothing
if he's not sober and measured and that
matters in the White House it matters in
Congress as well and and I think we've
lost that you write erratic behavior
unmoored from principle is the opposite
of conservatives that's right you know
during the Nixon era he had what was
called the madman theory he wanted our
adversaries to think that he was a
little off kilter that might provide
some strategic advantage but there has
to be some underlying strategy beneath
that and I don't sense that we have that
now and if you just have you know
erratic behavior unmoored from principle
that's not a good combination is Donald
Trump a Republican yes he's a Republican
from your description you're saying his
behavior does not match with the
principles of the Republican Party that
you carry well I do think that he has
some things that he has done have been
conservative I think he appointed a
great Supreme Court justice regulatory
policy that he has embraced is
conservative his instincts on tax
policy I think are conservative but some
things are profoundly unconservative the
protectionist attitude our attitude
toward free trade discounting free trade
agreements trying to get out of
multinational free trade agreements the
isolationism that that's not
conservative mean we worst exactly we
need desperately to play a game of
addition and not subtraction and you
know I think this campaign the 2016
campaign was all about drilling down on
a base and not adding two numbers let's
talk about this book you kept it a
secret from your staff while you were
writing it why well this was tough to
write I mean you never want to you know
particularly in an election year for me
or election period I'm up next year you
never want to upset the applecart or
talk about unpleasant things and so it
was difficult to write I didn't want to
be talked out of it though this is too
important I think we have a crisis of
principle and we need to get back to
what conservative really means and and I
think that's the combination for the
future so I I did keep it quiet and just
tell a couple of weeks ago and but now I
hope everyone reads it I hope people in
the White House and certainly my
colleagues as well you expect to have
the support of President Trump in your
reelection bid you know that's that's up
to him obviously there are only 52
senators we have a small majority but I
think we've reached about the limits of
what we can do just with our small
majority we've got to start reaching
across the aisle and and what bothers me
I think most is that the big problems
that we have to deal with whether it's
foreign policy issues or domestic
problems like our looming debt and
deficit 20 trillion dollars in debt will
be soon adding again a trillion dollars
a year in deficit to that debt you can
only do that if both parties sit down
and share the risk and that's not going
to happen when you refer to the other
party as my enemies or losers or clowns
you can't sit down together if in fact
you had a the President had tried to
negotiate in terms of infrastructure and
I moved to healthcare would have
had a better opportunity of fashioning a
healthcare bill that would have repaired
about McAra rather than repealing it I
do think so I think we should have
started with something else keep in mind
I mean I mean from Arizona its ground
zero for the failure of the exchange
we have people paying exorbitant
premiums two hundred thousand Arizonans
will wake up today with no health care
most of them used to have it but it's
gone now because premiums are too high
and they can't buy it on the exchange so
we desperately need reforms there the
president has talked and tweeted
recently about changing the voting rules
essentially doing away with the
filibuster is that does that have
prospects of happening no and it
shouldn't that would be a big mistake we
are at our best in the Senate when we
work across the aisle I think Obama care
many of the problems that it has because
it was pushed through by one party by
the same token we've found it difficult
as one party to repeal it and so I don't
want to lurch back and forth every
couple of years from one extreme to
another the Senate the genius of the
Senate is that you know it's a saucer
that cools the milk as as George
Washington said at one point those rules
are there for a reason they're good they
force us to work across the aisle they
invite us to work across the aisle and
we're better when we do that your
dedication is to that girl I met on a
faraway beach so long ago I'm assuming
that is your wife we met on the beach on
the north shore you know why BYU has a
campus there in the first day of school
thank you for coming senator thank you
much thank you senator